من بيروت ومعنا العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك عميد الياس
حنا ماذا يريد كل طرف ان يحقق من الاعتماد
على سلاح المسيرات
السيرات لا تربح الحرب يعني هي
اله هي وسيله من وسائل الحرب الاخرى من
ضمن الاسلحه الاخرى هي الاقل كلفه الاكثر
فعاليه بالمعنى الاعلامي الى حد ما يعني
عندما نتحدث عن استهداف المفاعل النووي في
كورسك يعني هذا المفاعل هو مجهز ضد الحرب
ضد النووي ضد حتى الزلازل ولن تؤثر فيها
هذا هذه المسيره ولكن اليوم المسيره هي
المدفعيه بعيده المدى الاقل كلفه وهي لمن
ليس لديه سلاح طيران اليوم الاكثر استعمال
يعني على سبيل المثال روسيه تستعمل
المسيرات والقنابل والصواريخ الباليستيه
والكروز في نفس الوقت فقط لاستهلاك
واستنزاف واشغال الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ولكن المسيرات لن تربح الحرب
بالمعنى حسم الحرب ولكن راينا هجمات مكثفه
له سيارات الروسيه على كييف بالمقابل
اليوم ايضا هجمات لمسيرات اوكرانيه
استهدفت من بين من استهدفت هذه المحطه
النوويه في كورسك ما الرسائل من كل ذلك
الرسائل يعني السلوك الروسي هو استمرار
لمرحله منذ منذ بدء معارك مخموت مع
الجنرال الروسي سلوفيكين الذي اقترح القصف
المستمر والقصف الاستراتيجي لكل المرافق
والبنى التحتيه الاوكرانيه نحن اليوم في
هذا الاطار على سبيل المثال ال سي هناك
معمل اتفق عليه بين ايران وروسيا لتجميع
وتصنيع الشاهد في منطقه طرطستان اثنين
هناك
معامل لتجميع المسيرات التركيه في
اوكرانيا كثره الاستعمال تؤدي في وقت من
الاوقات الى تحسين اداء هذه المسيرات ولكن
في اخر الامر من يحتل الارض هو الذي ينهي
الحرب خاصه في هذه الحرب الاوكرانيه وفي
هذا الاطار وانطلاقا من هذا الكلام عميد
الياس حنا كيف يمكن تقييم الحديث
الاوكراني اليوم الذي اتى كانه اشبه
باقرار ان الهجوم المضاد لم يحقق المنشود
حتى الان
الطبيعي ال سي اليوم كان لدى روسيا اكثر
من اربعه خمسه اشهر لتحضير الدفاع المرن
فليكس كما يقال على عمق 30 كيلومتر واليوم
ما يفتقده الجيش الاوكراني هو الدفاعات
الجويه ضد القوى المتنقله على دفاع فيه
الالغام المضاده للدبابات والاشخاص فيه
الخنادق فيه الحفر المضاده للدبابات مع
تفوق جوي
روسي هذا الامر يزعج
الدفاعات يعني الهجوم الاوكراني الذي لم
يحقق حتى الان الا في منطقه بخموت التقدم
بسيط ولكن ماذا لو تحول هذا الهجوم المضاد
الى هجمات طويله الامد لا تحقق تقدم عملي
ويحدث فارقا على الارض على غرار ما كان
يحدث قبل هذا الهجوم المضاد ماذا لو وصلنا
الى هذه النقطه
اذا وصلنا الى هذه النقطه قد نذهب الى ما
يسمى بستيل ميت على الطريقه الكوريه
بالعام 52 تصبح المنطقه منطقه عازله وهنا
يدخل قرارات النيتو ال سي اعطاء ضمانات
امنيه اعطاء الاف 16 وبالتالي هي موضوع
الحمايه يعني منع تقدم روسي اكثر من
المنطقه التي تقدم عليها وهنا يدور الجدل
انضمام الى النيتو او عدم انضمام اوكرانيا
الى النيتو واضح شكرا جزيلا لك العميد
الياس حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
ضيفنا من بيروت